[Musik]
die richtigen fragen bei bild herzlich
willkommen existenzangst in deutschland
gibt es immer mehr leute die sich für
ihr brot die butter nicht mehr leisten
können ein paket butter jetzt
tatsächlich so teuer so wertvoll
geworden dass lidl damit begonnen hat
dort extra sicherheitsetiketten
draufzukleben gegen butter diebstahl da
und dieser politik promi hier oskar
lafontaine der sagt in dieser energie
krise werden wir erheblich mehr armut
bekommen existenzangst droht deutschland
der komplett absturz darüber diskutiere
ich mit ihm und außerdem mit diesen
gästen hier bei uns im bild studio
nämlich mit anton hofreiter dem grünen
bundestagsabgeordneten mit sigmund
gottlieb dem langjährigen chefredakteur
des bayerischen rundfunks und autoren
und mit thomas middelhoff dem einzigen
spitzenmanager chef von karstadt war er
un chef von bertelsmann in allen
herzlich willkommen herr lafontaine wie
arm wird in dieser krise deutschland
werden
herr lafontaine wie arm wird deutschland
werden in dieser krise
es ist auf jeden fall sicher dass
verluste eintreten werden natürlich kann
niemand sagen was am ende das ergebnis
sein wird aber es gibt ja eine ganze
reihe von sachverständigen die meinen 20
prozent verlust an wohlstand sei zu
befürchten und das wäre ja für viele
menschen eine einbuße die sie nicht
verkraften würden
herr hofreiter wir reden heute abend
über existenzängste er menschen die
wirklich angst vorm absturz haben haben
sie diese menschen auch mit in diese
situation gebracht ich würde es so sagen
der angriffskrieg putins gegen die
ukraine hat diese menschen in die
situation gebracht und man kann jetzt
darüber streiten ob die regierung schon
alles getan hat was notwendig ist um die
folgen abzumildern
und da würde ich sagen nein da gibt es
noch einiges zu tun das ist eine
strompreis bremse angekündigt die haben
meisten angst haben ja die leute
versteigen
energiekosten die ja völlig durch die
decke gehen die zahlen die längst haben
nicht nur anlass die zahlen ja die
zahlen die zum teil ich machen das sind
ja längst und deswegen brauchen wir in
meinen augen so schnell wie möglich eine
strompreis bremse und ich würde sagen
wir brauchen auch dringend eine gaspreis
bremse welches sind die beiden
hauptursachen dafür wovor die menschen
angst haben es ist ja schon schwung
getragen worden das gab es schon
entlastungspaket 1 2 und 3 es ist für
rentner innen was getan worden es ist
für studio geschlossen dauert noch
monate bis das auf dem weg kommt die gas
abzulassen aber jetzt eben schon
gewohnheit sachen es heute auch schon
auf dem weg aber wie gesagt wir müssen
noch mehr tun schauen wir gerade die
regierung dabei inklusive deutschland
beim verfall beim zerfall zu dass ein
hartes wort das habe ich auch
formuliert von kurzem in diese richtung
ich denke dass die aktuellen
energiepreis
probleme
zusammenfallen mit einer schon länger
anhaltenden in der tat
zerfalls entwicklung im land in fast
allen bereichen einfach dass wir sowohl
den eliten wie auch im mittelstand wie
auch wir alle nicht mehr bereit sind den
spitzenplatz einnehmen so wollen wir
lassen nach wird wir ruhen uns auf
unserem weg ostern hat in der tabelle
wir rutschen ab sind schon abgerutscht
in der tabelle und greifen jetzt
natürlich auch noch in die anderen
bereiche die noch gut funktionieren
hinein und das passiert schon seit
einigen jahren und das ist extrem
bedenklich und dann kommen im grunde
zwei linien zusammen die in einer
fatalen wirkung enden können ohne dass
man jetzt ganz anderer rufen möchte herr
middelhoff ich habe gerade das beispiel
von der butter gezeigt bei lidl wo
neuerdings in allen filialen
sicherheitsetiketten draufkleben weil
man diebstahl fürchtet bei einem alltags
produkt sowohl das bis vor kurzem butter
das war mal deutsches wirtschaftswunder
dass man endlich dick butter aufs brot
streichen konnte was sagt das heute über
unser land aus dass butter im grunde zum
luxusgut wird ich glaube anknüpfend an
das was er gottlieb gesagt das problem
aktuell ist nicht die butter sondern das
problem aktuell ist dass wir
restrukturierungsbedarf haben in
deutschland durch die politik durch die
wirtschaft in allen bereichen und darauf
dass kommt was herr hofreiter
angesprochen hat ukraine ja und die
damit verbundenen probleme und
energiepreis steigung und dass dann das
zu befürchten ist was er lafontaine eben
dargelegt hat ein ganz massiver
einkommensverlust ganz massive
schieflage im bereich der privaten
haushalte groß ist jetzt der anteil der
regierung an dieser krise daran dass so
viele um ihren wohlstand fürchten dass
dann müssen wir die regierung
auseinander halten ich glaube die erste
teil die strukturellen probleme die
gehen eindeutig auf das konto derjenigen
die ungefähr 20 jahre lang verantwortung
für dieses land hatten ganz eindeutig
nachholbedarf in der digitalisierung
energieversorgung total abhängigkeit von
russland das ist ja nicht jetzt
entstanden das was wir jetzt aber
brauchen ist ein masterplan also was wir
jetzt nicht brauchen ist nochmal news
paket nochmals natürlich müssen wir den
bedürftigen helfen aber wir müssen noch
die directions vorgeben wir müssen auch
sagen in diese richtung wird dieses land
gesteuert jeder mal an die rede von
bundespräsident herzog die ruck rede wo
er gesagt hat alle sind angesprochen
alle müssen beitrag leisten und das ist
das was wir jetzt uns klar sein der rock
ist nämlich nach wie vor nicht gekommen
nach yahoo krone die politik die politik
allein kann das nicht richten wir sind
in einer situation in dem jeden klar
sein muss ihm das auch gesagt werden
muss dass jeder einen beitrag leisten
muss und gleichzeitig müssen nie
abgesichert werden die nicht in der lage
sind das zu überstehen jetzt hat er
mittelhof herr lafontaine den beitrag
auch der alten regierung der regierung
merkel genannt wie hoch ist der beitrag
an dieser krise von dem mann bzw dessen
regierung hier neben mir sitzt von anton
hofreiter
also wir müssen das hauptproblem sind
das hauptproblem ist die entwicklung der
energiepreise
und ich sehe nicht dass die
vorgängerregierung von der jetzt die
rede war die entwicklung der
energiepreise in größerem umfang
beeinflusst hat
beeinflusst wurde diese entwicklung
durch die entscheidung viele
aktionspakete zu machen und die reaktion
der russen auf diese sanktionspaket mit
einschränkungen der energielieferungen
zu antworten das heißt also die
kernfrage ist nicht unbedingt
dies oder jenes was jetzt entschieden
wird die kernfrage ist wie kriegen wir
die energie preise runter und da muss
die bundesregierung das ist ihr anteil
endlich begreifen dass ihre entscheidung
diese ganzen sanktionspaket mitzutragen
das gebäude hat die rede davon wir
wollen jetzt unabhängig vom gas seien
sofort und wir wollen was weiß ich vom
öl das wollen wir auch abschaffen dass
diese entscheidung einfach völlig
überhöht waren wenn man sich also schon
lösen will von einem lieferanten dann
muss man das behutsam machen dass man
nicht selber eben sich ein bein stellt
und jetzt sieht man dass eben der große
standortvorteil der deutschen industrie
das war in den niedrigen energiepreise
durch fehlentscheidungen der regierung
die eben dann die russische reaktion
hervorgerufen haben
letztendlich gekommen sind und das
sicher nicht nur die industrie die leute
sind es auch die bevölkerung geleitet
und die regierung muss jetzt endlich
begreifen dass sie auf dem falschen weg
ist muss umkehren
wir werden denn wohlstand ohne billige
energie nicht halten können und billige
energie gibt es nicht aus katar nicht
aus den usa nicht sonst wo her sie gibt
es nur aus russland wer das nicht
begreift verschließt die augen vor der
wirklichkeit also eher hofreiter
lafontaine macht ganz klar sie
beziehungsweise die aktuelle ampel
regierung dafür verantwortlich und sagt
sie haben den einfachen ausweg sie
brauchen halt die russische energie die
sanktionspolitik ist schuld da der
deswegen verlieren wir den wohlstand
hier in deutschland das ist die
klassische reaktion der putin vor ende
der leute die die fünfte kolonne putins
hier bei uns darstellen und die
demokratie an die diktatur ausliefern
wollen das ist typisch es ist nichts
anderes zu erwarten
dabei funktionieren die sanktionen
extrem gut russlands überschüsse sind im
august kollabiert die sanktionen führen
bereits dazu dass die russische
rüstungsindustrie lacht darüber helle
rafi lacht darüber kann er darüber
lachen aber die zahlen sind eindeutig
wird am erhöhen orientieren und an den
preisen nicht von putin verstehen und
ähnlichem reden sie müssen eine antwort
geben die halbwegs ernst zu nehmen ist
wie kriegen wir die preise runter dass
ein markt vorgang wenn man also die
russischen gasmengen und ölmengen von
europäischen markt wegnimmt dann muss
europa zu überteuerten preisen überall
in der welt einkaufen und sie sind damit
mich verantwortlich für diesen anstieg
der preise und wenn sie das nicht
verstehen da sind sie mitverantwortlich
für die verarmung der bevölkerung das
sind tatsachen da kann man nicht mehr
herum reden und nicht sagen gut den
verstehe oder ähnlichen und das ist ein
brutaler vorwurf an sie herr hofreiter
bzw an ihren wirtschaftsminister an
ihrem bundeskanzler mein gott das ist
halt die propaganda putins die immer
wieder hier in deutschland wiederholt
wird verantwortlich ist natürlich putin
mit seinem angriff auf die ukraine ohne
jeden grund also ohne also dass weiteren
und jetzt rede ich erstmal erla von
tieren und desweiteren sozusagen haben
wir deshalb sanktionen erlassen um
diesen krieg zu beenden und die
sanktionen wirken im august so zu sagen
hat russland massive staatsdefizit und
sie bewirken auch dass die russische
rüstungsindustrie
bereits in großen schwierigkeiten ist
die firma sun erneuten russischen
panzern immer öfters waschmaschinen und
spülmaschinen chips und man darf nicht
vergessen die russische armee foltert
mordet vergewaltigt und da einfach zu
sagen das ist uns egal wir machen
einfach so weiter und kaufen bei dieser
diktatur billigenergie das ist einfach
mehr als unanständig und wird uns
langfristig wenn wir es so machen dann
ökonomisch noch viel mehr kosten weil
wir nämlich viel in die anderen
europäischen länder exportieren viele
die usa exportieren und als verbündeter
eines aller leiden diktatorischen
russlands wird man den wohlstand ganz
sicher vorteil sie sagen herr hofreiter
sind die menschen hier ist die neue
armut hier in deutschland egal hofreiter
pfeffer zurück und sagt ihnen sind die
massengräber egal ihnen sind die
kriegsverbrechen egal
das ist nun leider eben
soll ich mal sagen sag' ich überhaupt
nicht haltbar nach der aussage von einem
hof weiter ist zum beispiel frankreich
ein unmögliches land weil das hat ja
seine gas einfuhren aus russland enorm
gesteigert ich weiß noch bei hochreiter
das weist denn ist also dann alles egal
oder ich nehme mir japan die machen eine
solche dummheit muss ich sagen nicht wie
die deutsche regierung die sagen also
die industriestadt wir verzichten nicht
auf russisches gas wir beuten sogar mit
den russen zusammen die gasvorräte auf
sachalin aus also so dumm wie die
deutsche regierung stellt sich keine
regierung in der welt an das muss man in
dieser härte sagen ganz kurz ist es auch
will ankara sind laut sie von dieser
leben frankreich und japan halten sich
an die sanktionen es gab nämlich nie
sanktionen gegen russisches gas das ist
einfach die entscheidung von putin und
wenn putin morgen entscheidet frankreich
nichts mehr zu liefern liegt frankreich
nichts mehr gesagt wieder kurz 2011
leiter ganz kurz natürlich sind uns die
arme leute nicht egal deswegen gibt's
entlastungspaket und deswegen habe ich
geschafft muss auch noch mehr passiert
und zwar in meinen augen ein strompreis
deckel und nehers presste ist angekommen
herrgott jetzt zeigt dieser streit ja
genau das dilemma in dem wir gerade
stecken wir haben diese woche berichtet
über den rentner dittmar aus zwickau der
seine erste gas abschlagszahlung
bekommen hat und derzeit genau das was
herr lafontaine gerade gesagt hat der
hat sein leben lang gearbeitet er hat
eine ordentliche rente und jetzt bekommt
er auf einen schlag monats
abschlagszahlung von
2200 euro und sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr auf den tisch der wird sich sehr
schwer tun herrn hofreiter noch
zuzuhören und zu sagen ja das ist weiter
richtig mit den sanktionen das ist
weiter richtung richtig mit den waffen
liefern ich falle ja hier gerade an
wohlstand wie das ist immer das dilemma
wir haben nicht nur an wohlstand
wahrscheinlich geht es bei ihm gar nicht
mehr oder ruhestand sondern es geht um
die existenz 61 sein existenzminimum im
wahrsten sinn des wortes und der rentner
wird weiter sagen also einen streit über
ihn eben hier erlebt haben der hilft mir
nicht weiter dass es wieder der
klassische politische intro veit sondern
ich möchte wissen wie ich durch den
winter kommen mit welchen mitteln mit
welchen maßnahmen mich diese
bundesregierung die aus 3
parteien besteht unterstützen wird so
dass ich nicht im kalten wohnzimmer
sitzen und dass ich meine und melodie
mit der butter bestreichen kann von der
sie eben gesprochen haben in der tat und
dann steht der renter drittens fest dass
er im augenblick wenn herr hofreiter
sagt da ist der gaspreis deckel in
aussicht da ist der stromkreis decke in
aussicht wenn wir das sagen ja in
aussicht aber es ist noch nicht
vollzogen es ist noch nichts gemacht und
ich habe gestern noch mit einer reihe
von unternehmen des mittelstandes des
kleinen mittelstandes gesprochen und die
sagen ja ankündigung jeden tag eine neue
umsetzung 0 das heißt also dieser
rentner steht nach diesem streit
lafontaine hofreiter und nach dieser
bisherigen energie
deckelung sub sicht steht vor 0
position also das heißt er wird sich
überhaupt hier nicht aufgehoben fühlen
und da rauskommen gott dass ich meine
ich dass inter wäre das auch sagen ja
das ist wirklich das qualitäts erst
mache ich diese regierung zu der auch
die grünen natürlich gehören wir sie
wissen mache ich das zum vorwurf das ist
ein komplexes riesiges thema das wir im
augenblick besprechen da möchte ich mit
keinem verantwortlichen politiker
tauschen wir tun uns leicht hier
sozusagen die die gute option hier zu
fordern aber ich erwarte handwerk und
ich erwarte schnelle umsetzung und ich
erwarte auch einen tisch an dem ich mich
mit den leuten setzte die davon
betroffen sind mit den unternehmen an
all das ist nur bisher mit verzögerung
passiert und wenn sie mit harwig reden
dann gibt er ihnen das inzwischen auch
sie sind sie sind unternehmer sie sind
manager gewesen ganz lange zeit der
mittel auf stimmt das was herr gott
liebt gerade sagt die fühlen sich gar
nicht mitgenommen die die klagen über
inkompetenz über fachkräftemangel
innerhalb der bundesregierung ich stimme
herrn gottlieb absolut zu und wenn ich
noch mal einen schritt zurückgehen örv
ich möchte herrn lafontaine an einem
punkt widersprechen die verantwortung
für die abhängigkeit energieabhängigkeit
von russland ja die ist so entschieden
so entwickelt worden und es war doch
jedem deutlich dass deutschland ein land
ohne ressourcen ohne energieressourcen
ist und da ist was wahres dran ist
bringen da heute uns allen natürlich gar
nicht wer schuld leider mal nein ist es
schon wichtig für die entscheidung
kurzfristig mittelfristig und
langfristig wie wichtig dieses land neu
aus kurzfristig kommen wir doch relativ
schnell zu der frage ja sanktionen ja
position beziehen im rahmen der ukraine
krieges aber auf der anderen seite sind
wir bereit doch mit russland zu
verhandeln um gas und energieversorgung
sicherzustellen ja oder nein und da
möchte ich mal einen deutschen minister
sehen deren amtseid abgelegt hat dass er
also zum wohle der bevölkerung und union
ab hält das ist eine ganz schwierige
entscheidungssituationen so was wir
brauchen ist genau das was er gesagt
weil sie mit der schwierigen
entscheidungspositionen relation unser
commitment zu westlicher welt ja und
verteidigung der demokratie moralische
werte vor allen dingen und auf der
anderen seite versorgung der bürger der
das ist ein interessanter artikel hofft
mit energie die bezwang schauen wir uns
noch mal an wir schauen uns nochmal den
amtseid des bundeskanzlers an wie das im
bundestag außer vorne dreiviertel jahr
etwa das ist der eid den der kanzler zu
sprechen hat und viele deutsche sagen
jetzt mensch der hält sich jetzt nicht
dran mit seiner energiepolitik aktuellen
wir schauen uns nochmal an seinen
amtseid
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden
tut er das schaden von ihm zuwenden wenn
leute wie dieser rentner dietmar den wir
besucht haben in zwickau eine unfassbare
energierechnung hat eine rechnung die
höher ist als sie möglicherweise sein
müsste er tut es nicht wenn ihr die
wichtigen entscheidungen ungefähren
belässt also wenn im ungefähren bleibt
ob kanzler geliefert werden oder nicht
und im ungefähren bleibt wie denn
bezahlbare energie jetzt in den
wintermonaten zur verfügung gestellt
werden soll und wenn dann der bürger
fast jeden tag neue ta ta nachrichten
bekommt ja dann muss man sich nicht
wundern dass die ich würde mal sagen das
vertrauen in die politischen führung ein
masters angekratzt ist herr hofreiter
ehrt sie also ermittler hofft er sagt
hier ist sogar der amtszeit sozusagen
denen man geschworen hat der wird nicht
wirklich mit leben gefüllt aktuell es
wird alles im ungefähren gelassen auch
die strompreise im ungefähren die
gaspreise im ungefähren also ich meine
ich habe schon öfters kritisiert aber
irgendwann wird zeit doch albern oder
billig man sollte doch mal die kirche im
dorf lassen gleich darum zeit verletzt
dann was weiß ich man muss sofort alles
machen ja immer an die regierung ja die
regierung so zu sagen hat innerhalb
kürzester zeit sind wir dabei gas
terminal zu bauen wir lassen die
atomkraftwerke länger laufen
doch die viele ist das die erste neu das
wäre eine echte meldung sie lassen die
atomkraftwerke länger laufen wird wenn
es mit der einschränkung ja klar sie
dürfen nicht mehr strom produzieren als
sie benötigen sonst kriegen sie das netz
auch zum krachen das hat man schon mal
dann wir haben wahrscheinlich ende des
jahres das erste gas terminal das ist
innerhalb weniger eines jahres dann wir
haben bereits drei entlastungspaket andy
hat schon gesagt ja ich bin der meinung
und das kritisiere ich auch dass die
regierung sich noch nicht entschieden
hat an strompreis deckel und an gaspreis
deckel für den durchschnittsverbraucher
zu erlassen aber sozusagen sich diese
vielzahl von krisen anzuschauen und wir
haben ja noch weitere krisen die
klimakrise ist dieses jahr auch wieder
völlig eskaliert rhein hatte fast kein
wasser mehr deswegen konnten die schiffe
nicht drauf vernünftig fahren usw diese
vielzahl von krisen und dann zwar alles
was in 16 jahren versäumt worden ist
aber
das hat keine fordert man hat sofort
einfach das waren wir zuerst gegen die
frage dem höher weil wir alle die
abschlagszahlung hat sich vor
ein entlassener geht das wir sind immer
feiern das ist beschlossen aber da ist
noch immer sauer das ist ganz ganz weit
in der jahn ist aber das war wahr ist
sagte hofreiter
die waren beide aber ich war als heute
die kirche auch irgendwo in dollar
belassen sie in jedem traf sie
übertreiben einfach ermittelt hat so
ähnlich formuliert die im moment sagen
mensch die haben die interessen der
menschen in der ukraine im blick aber
unsere unsere interessen unser
portemonnaie das haben die im moment
viel zu wenig im blick
das stimmt auf den ersten blick ist das
eine eine richtige feststellen auf den
zweiten blick würde ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen in richtung hofreiter gehen und
sagen also machen wir es mal jetzt an
bundeskanzler fest sozusagen diesen
schaden vom rentner abzuhalten hat
natürlich eine zweifache dimension ist
einmal die sozusagen ökonomische
existenzminimum ebene und das andere ist
sozusagen die globale auch der rentner
huber wie immer er heißt mag und will in
frieden leben und erwartet von der
regierung im lande natürlich dass sie
die voraussetzungen für eine solche so
friedlichen und meinem herrgott und drei
wochen erklärt auf eine ebene bringen
und da sage ich müssen sie erklären da
haben wir ein gewaltiges erklärungs
defizit in der regierung und vor allem
ein gewaltiges erklärungs defizit beim
bundeskanzler hella fontaine es gibt
eine sehr prominente stimme im moment in
der politik die auch genau das sagt
sahra wagenknecht sie hat eine sehr
umstrittene rede im bundestag gehalten
und sie sagt aktuell auch das nämlich
dass die interessen der menschen in der
ukraine angeblich und da bezieht sich
auch auf die worte der außenministerin
ja mehr zählen würden als die interessen
vieler deutschen ich nehme an die
meinung ist konsens im hause
sie sehen das völlig richtig ich würde
mich überhaupt nicht wagen ihr zu
widersprechen aber scherz beiseite
die kernfrage ist doch die wie können
wir den menschen in deutschland helfen
und das ist ja von einem mittel darauf
angesprochen weil er hat gesagt wir
müssen die frage beantworten ob wir mit
russland über lieferung von energie
verhandelt nun kann man sagen wie die
bundesregierung oder andere oder die
sich nicht trauen oder zu feige sind
nein machen wir nicht wir wollen den
putin bestrafen kann man alles machen
dann sage ich dann bleiben die
energiepreise aus markt gründen wenn die
russen mengen nicht kommen bleiben auf
sehr hohem niveau und damit sind
diejenigen die die russischen mengen
ablehnen schuld für die hohen preise die
menschen in deutschland begreifen dass
langsam kürzlich hat ermittelt dass die
öffnung von 19 2 von einer mehrheit der
menschen mittlerweile als für richtig
gehalten wird weil die menschen ja sehen
alle päckchen geschnürt werden den nicht
auf das eigentliche problem und das
eigentliche problem ist nach wie vor wie
kriegen wir die gaspreise runter wer
einen besseren weg hat als die
behandlung mit russland der soll ihn
nennen aber bisher haben wir eben nur
vorschläge gehört die alle nicht
funktionieren das setzen auf flüssiggas
ist an der preislage geradezu absurd das
heißt sie würden im moment herr
lafontaine habe ich sie richtig
verstanden wenn sie in der rolle wären
nach moskau reisen
selbstverständlich würde ich eben
verhandlungen aufnehmen denn wir werden
auf dauer ich sage das in aller klarheit
es geht nicht nur um gas oder öl die in
deutsche industrie wird auf dauer ohne
russische rohstoffe nicht bestehen
können wir werden das in den nächsten
monaten drastisch vor augen geführt
bekommen herr hofreiter ihrer
außenministerin lehnt das kategorisch
ablehnt dieses gespräch mit lawrow ab
herr scholz telefoniert metall putin
lehnt aber diese verhandlung ab das ist
im moment in der regierung absolut
konsens werden wir wird ihre regierung
zu diesem punkt kommen wenn die
gaspreise eben unbezahlbar sind wenn der
druck von der straße massiv wird nein
selbstverständlich würden dem
kriegsverbrecher und weiteres geld in
den rachen stopfen und man muss halt
wieder sagen und es ist ja dann billig
zu sagen dass das polymer mehr geld in
den rachen die heimat steuerhoheit also
manchmal reden sondern der punkt ist
wenn die nordstream 2 auf machen wir
haben drei pipelines es gibt überhaupt
keine sanktionen auf gas ich helfe dir
die für sinnvoller es gibt sie nicht und
3.0 ist 0 und 4 0 ist auch 0 das ist
simpelste mathematik und das kann man
halt auch verstehen aber wenn man halt
ideologisch völlig verbohrt ist dann
will das wird einfach schlecht ich nicht
verstehen und deswegen muss man heute
noch ist fertig dass die russischen
energien ist flanken sagen müsse es
bleibt die frage und da sind sie auf dem
weg der wird nur langfristig erst
erfolgen oder mittelfristig erfolgen es
bleibt die frage nach der gewichtung
wenn eben hier der wohlstand verloren
geht und die menschen fragen warum dreht
ihr nicht einfach an dem gas zähnchen
warum löst hier nicht zuerst mein
energieproblem ein kostenproblem und
dann kümmert ihr euch um die ukraine was
antworten sie erstens weil es dazu
führen würde dass touristische krieg
gegen die ukraine wahrscheinlich länger
dauern würde und damit die probleme
länger dauern weil wir sagen die
kriegsmaschinerie noch mal stärker mit
geld fördern würden zweitens gar nicht
in der hand haben weil nämlich die
sanktionen gar nicht gegen russisches
erdgas erlassen worden sind die gibt es
nämlich gar nicht nämlich die bedingung
von putin ist wir hören auf die ukraine
zu unterstützen das muss man mal ganz
klar sagen man kann mit putin darüber
verhandeln aber die bedingung ist wir
liefern keine waffen mehr an die ukraine
und werfen die ukraine einem
faschistoiden system zum fraß vor das
ist die bedingung das heißt herr
lafontaine sagt hier ich will für
billiges gas das die russische armee in
der gesamten ukraine morden und
vergewaltigen darf das ist sozusagen das
was er von der regierung verlangt und
das muss man mit der klarheit sein und
ich glaube wenn sie die leute fragen
würden wollen sie wirklich für billiges
erdgas das in der ukraine kinder
vergewaltigt werden und es hätte wäre
die konsequenz villa keine waffen mehr
die vermögen würden die leute die nein
sagen deswegen müssen wir trotzdem mehr
tun um die leute zu unterstützen für die
übergangsphase wo die energiepreise sind
das bestreite ich überhaupt nicht und
das werfe ich unsere regierung auch mit
vor uns allen die wird auch
verantwortung tragen dass wir doch nicht
schnell genug sein denn sie haben völlig
recht dem rentner hilft nichts wenn er
heute zahlen muss wenn in zwei monaten
bei hella von preis täglich darauf herr
lafontaine
ja das ist eben das geräte der grünen
seien länger aber sie sind ja mehr oder
weniger jetzt an die wand gelaufen ihre
vorwürfe würden japan und frankreich
treffen das ist absurd die werfen die
ukraine in rüssen zum fraß vor die
japaner haben wer in der birne als wir
die wissen dass ihre industrie energie
brauchen das gilt eben auch für uns die
grünen wären es auch noch begreifen
unsere industrie braucht energie und mit
gerede und mit irgendwelchen kutil
versteher geschwätz ich da überhaupt
nicht geregelt ohne russische rohstoffe
und energie können wir unseren wohlstand
nicht erarbeiten und deshalb muss ich
ihnen sagen sie werden mitverantwortlich
sein für den niedergang der deutschen
wirtschaft und die verarmung weiter
teile der bevölkerung wären sie um es
gibt keinen anderen weg jetzt hating oft
ganz kurz die unwahrheit wird nicht
dadurch wahr wenn man sie wiederholt
herr lafontaine ich habe ihnen schon
einmal gesagt es gibt gar keine
sanktionen auch für sie
selbstverständlich das haben wir
verstanden herr hofreiter herr
middelhoff stimmt dass ohne russisches
gas ist es zwangsläufig der niedergang
unseres wohlstands der niedergang
unserer industrie ich würde zunächst mal
vorschlagen dass wir uns auf das
konzentrieren das was wir aus deutscher
sicht machen können und gestalten können
das ist die laufzeitverlängerung der akw
katastrophe alter kommt stattdessen
reden wir über uns da muss man auch
seite so ein bisschen die kirche im dorf
lassen auch bei der argumentation
also das ist erstmal eine klare
entscheidung eine klare message was
zumindest mal planungsgrundlagen
hervorruft dann kann man ihn gehen und
sagen über welches delta sprechen wir ja
eigentlich wenn wir auf der einen seite
das seine energie werden wir auf der
einsatz richtig wenn wir auf der einen
seite dann einen preis decknamen dann
wissen wir erst mal so kommen wir
einigermaßen vor allen dingen für die
einkommensschwachen über die runden
liegen die industrie kann weiter plan so
und das nächste ist das was herr
lafontaine gesagt hat ich halte es nicht
für ausgeschlossen dass man das eine tun
und das andere nicht lassen kann nämlich
dass man eine moralische position hat
aber gleichzeitig den zwang hat und die
verpflichtungen aus auch wenn sie das
nicht hören er hofreiter aus einem
daraus und aus der politischen
verpflichtungen heraus alles dafür zu
tun dass die energie die übrigens auch
die industrie bord der gegen lafontaine
recht bekommt denn experten waren ja
längst von einem blackout und das sind
nicht mehr irgendwelche spinner sind
dass das sind diejenigen die das einfach
dieses delta wie ehrhoff ausrechnen also
dass das problem ist doch
streiten jetzt sehr stark über diesen
weg der im augenblick noch in keiner
weise begangen ist von der handelnden
regierung es sind ja nur vorschläge da
ist ja noch nichts in der umsetzung noch
mal wenn sie mit den unternehmern reden
hofreiter müssen sie nicht mit dem kopf
schütteln der redens in ihrem wahlkreis
mit unternehmern das tun sie sicher auch
dann sagen die ihnen wir haben im moment
noch keine panik bezüglich dieser
energie situation aber wir haben mehr
und sagen sie das so in der sendung
haben sie gesagt wir haben mehr als
große sorgen was die energiesituation
angeht wir haben 7000 energieintensive
unternehmen mit einer million jobs in
deutschland
ich meine das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
ich würde auch in ihre richtung
argumentieren sagen im augenblick fehlt
mir noch die fantasie
wegen der energiefrage mich mit putin an
einen tisch zu setzen das kann ich mir
im moment nicht vor mir habe ich genug
moral
es aber im all along mittelfristig
auszuschließen wäre naiv hält bode hält
moral politisch naiv und es wäre auch
gefährlich deshalb ist diese überlegung
die herr middelhoff angesprochen hat
absolut nicht weiter und zielgenau
herrgott wenn ich einmal stechen darf
bei ihm dauert das länger weil sie eine
gute pension haben weil es ihnen gut
geht bei den menschen die im moment auf
der straße sind ging das schneller weil
die bereits an der grenze sind die
können die strom abschlagszahlungen
bezahlen die gas abschlagszahlung bei
den geldbeuteln stellen auch nicht kasan
berufen sondern nur perspektivisch mir
vorstellen dass es mir durchaus
vorstellbar ist dass es im herbst
durchaus zu
demonstrationen gut gemeint gut gemeint
kommt nicht vom rechten und vom land das
ist dazu noch in einem ganz anderen um
wann kommt und darauf muss sich politik
vorbereiten und dann haben die leute auf
der straße wie gebhardt ist ja wie geben
direkt dorthin heute zum beispiel nach
freiberg in sachsen wieder eine
montagsdemonstration das was wir
mittlerweile seit wochen seit monaten
erleben und mit dabei unsere bild
reporterin klarer marie becker in
freiberg auf der straße was war heute
los was haben die leute gesagt und wer
war dort auf der straße
genau heute haben auch hier in freiberg
wieder hunderte menschen um genau zu
sein 600 menschen auf der straße
demonstriert bei den sogenannten
montagsdemo sagen ja wirklich
mittlerweile um die tausende oder
mehrere tausende auf die straßen hier in
ganz sachsen und hier in freiberg waren
heute wirklich menschen die von ihren
persönlichen problemen erzählt haben
keine rechtsextremisten keine
linksextremisten menschen die einfach
probleme haben im alltäglichen leben und
das jetzt schon spüren wären eine
familie getroffen die gesagt hat wir
haben jetzt wieder neue rechnungen
zugeschickt bekommen wir wissen nicht
mehr wie wir die bezahlen sollen die
stromrechnungen ist in die höhe
geschossen wir haben menschen getroffen
die erzählt haben oder uns gefragt haben
wir wissen inzwischen nicht mehr wo wir
hingehen soll mit unserem frust deswegen
gehen wir hier auf die straße wir wissen
nicht mehr wie wir unseren unmut kundtun
sollen wie wir unsere probleme nach
außen tragen sollen und was er hat ganz
häufig gehört haben immer wieder die
frage warum kümmern sich die politiker
mehr um die menschen in der ukraine als
um uns hier in freiberg das sind die
fragen ob man die mag oder nicht danke
klara marie becker für diesen
interessanten einblick heute nach
freiberg in sachsen das war nur eine von
ganz vielen demonstrationen allein heute
abend man mag die mögen oder nicht diese
fragen das sind die fragen die im moment
kommen herr hofreiter wie lange halten
sie ihren kurs durch bis fünf millionen
arbeitslose bis zum ersten längeren
blackout bis die autoindustrie am boden
ist was ist der punkt wo sie frische
nicht mehr argumentieren können keinen
er fehlt ja in sanktionskurs und das ist
natürlich halt einfach quatsch was sie
erzählt mit der ist nicht so leicht auch
mit natürlichkeit zu sagen nämlich es
stimmt schlichtweg nicht wir sind dabei
flüssiggas terminal zu bauen innerhalb
von monaten ja das ist mit ihrer
geschwindigkeit wir sind gerade dabei
eine ganze reihe von alten
kohlekraftwerken wieder ans netz zu
bringen wir haben ein riesen
gesetzespaket zur beschleunigung des
ausbaus des erneut das haben ja alles
gehört lassen wir uns die zeit nur ja
tatsächlich in einen wagen zu reden das
problem ist wenn so das läuft doch ihr
problem nicht wenn ich hier behauptet
wird die regierung hat keinen plan und
dann vor ort sage genau das zu machen
und dann ist der plan in vielen teilen
bereits gesetzeskraft gewartet dann
stimmt es halt nicht und es hilft auch
sozusagen nichts es immer wieder zu
wiederholen
doch war nämlich vieles ist bereits
gesetzeskraft vieles ist bereits im bau
manche kohlekraftwerke laufe ja nochmal
und vor den drei atomkraftwerken werden
im herbst oder im dezember entschieden
nämlich im süden brauchen wir die unter
umständen ob sie weiter laufen oder
nicht und dh wir tun bereits wahnsinnig
fiel innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit und was
ich schon gesagt hat für die leute die
gerade ihre rechnungen kaum mehr
bezahlen können müssten wir und das
finde ich auch problematisch nicht nur
das was alles bereits beschlossen worden
ist dass die leute mehr geld kriegen das
pakete gibt für rentner pakete für
studierende sie haben zum beispiel die
energieintensive energie angesprungen da
gibt es bereits also sozusagen auch
entsprechend nämlich nicht wählen
unternehmen der energieintensiven
industrie zu helfen deswegen wollen wir
ja auch einen strompreis deckel und was
ich wie gesagt selber schon gesagt habe
ja wir bräuchten in meinen augen
schneller einen strompreis und gaspreis
deckel das ist das was ich selber
kritisiert was wir auch uns nehmen
müssen wo ich werbung dafür machen dass
das so schnell wie möglich passiert
lange wie möglich was heißt das ich bin
nicht ganz alleine an der regierung ich
bin sogar gar nicht an der regierung
sein aber ich bin ausschussvorsitzender
im parlament aber das nur am rande ich
sagte ich mache werbung dafür dass es so
schnell wie möglich passieren aber hier
so zu tun als wenn eine regierung die
ein gesetz nach dem anderen
verabschiedet die probleme doch sie
stellt ausgerechnet die atomkraftwerke
nach vorne die entscheidung hat nun
wirklich extrem lange gedauert aber wir
streiten gleich weiter darüber einmal
kurz danach von themen dass wir ganz
kurz im hause passiert ist mehr
lafontaine diese regierung die herr
hofreiter gerade noch mal lobt weil ein
wie er sagt gesetz nach dem nächsten
kommt wird die überhaupt noch das
nächste jahr erleben der druck in der
regierung ist massiv der druck von der
straße ist mittlerweile wie wir gerade
gesehen haben massiv
wenn sie nicht umkehren und einsehen
dass ihr weg falsch ist werden sie große
schwierigkeiten haben in einigen monaten
die ganze verzweiflung sieht man ja auch
daran dass jetzt in aserbaidschan
anklopfen über die europäische
kommission dass die dann gas liefern das
pech ist nur dass aserbaidschan eben
auch einen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg wird man sieht also dass
die regierung sich hoffnungslos verrannt
alten sie neuwahlen für ausgeschlossen
ich halte sie nicht für ausgeschlossen
wenn es nicht gelingt eben die soziale
lage in deutschland zu verbessern
und man muss daran erinnern dass das
erste pflicht der deutschen politik ist
sich um die menschen hier zu kümmern die
es in großer not sind wenn das nicht
gelingt halte ich für möglich dass eben
es immer ich da wieder wird in
deutschland neu war ein herr hofreiter
nicht mehr ausgeschlossen angesichts
dieser stimmungslage ist es natürlich
alles quatsch also wissen sie ich habe
ja schon häufig herrn schulz kritisiert
aber wenn man halt vollkommen maßlos den
teufel an die wand malt fdp gibt es
genau dieser absatz beginn erster
kreisverbände sagen beispielsweise
stralsund wie machen das nicht mehr mit
das hat gründe mit der korona krise aber
auch gründe weil die unternehmen druck
machen an der basis ich habe ja wie
gesagt schon gesagt dass wir da auch
noch einiges tun muss wir sind ja auch
donna lang netz um am ende aber wenn man
halt so völlig maßlos kritisiert
na ja sogar jemanden wie mich der einen
durchaus gemischten blick auf das
regierungshandeln plötzlich stolz über
den grünen klee zu loben wobei ich
einige punkte hätte wohl besser
kommunizieren müsste war in meinen augen
besser entscheiden müsste nämlich zum
beispiel endlich auch panzer an die
ukraine zu liefern heißt dieser krieg
schneller zu ende geht und so weiter
aber wenn man halt so wirklich völlig
maßlos agiert also dann würden wir immer
still doch völlig maßlos weiß ich
absolut zurück herr hofreiter wenn man
fakten schildern ja dann ist das nicht
maßlosigkeit sondern wir versuchen zu
analysieren wie die situation ist welche
usa
unternimmt das wort relation noch nicht
mal welche ursachen es hat und heute die
bundesbank hat gemeldet im nächsten jahr
inflationsrate zweistellig ich bin jetzt
fast 70 jahre alt ja ich habe eine
zweistellige inflationsrate nie erlebt
in meinem leben und ich muss sagen hätte
man das vor 20 oder 25 jahren
kommuniziert es wären aufstand durch die
republik ja es ist die zweite rezession
das relative hohe zwischen es gibt eine
korrelation zwischen inflationsraten und
arbeit das ist die ganze session die
deutschland dar
weil der hofreiter den gleich weil das
ja so über die frage wird die regierung
diese krise schaffen oder wird die krise
diese regierung schaffen gleich in einer
ganz kurzen pause zurück hier in einer
diskussion bei bild die richtigen fragen
[Musik]
millionen deutsche in existenzangst und
die frage was ist die lösung im moment
für alle die ihre gas abschläge ihre
strom- abschläge nicht mehr zahlen
können da sagt oskar lafontaine einer
unserer gäste heute abend wir müssen
sofort verhandeln mit russland wir
müssen sofort verhandeln mit putin das
ist der entscheidende weg dann spielen
wir das mal durch herr middelhoff würden
sie in der aktuellen situation
berichterstattung über massengräber über
immer neue angriffe würden sie wladimir
putin jetzt die hand geben
bei verhandlungen hierfür erst mal nicht
um hand gehen ja ist ja auch die frage
wer verhandelt mit wem ich glaube
zuständig für die lieferung von gas
zuteilung von gas an ausländische
abnehmer ist nicht herr putin selber
sondern ist jetzt irgendeine
organisation ja was wir konstruieren ist
dass das was wir dort abnehmen bezahlen
mir mit geld und dieses geld fließt
einem staat zu der völkerrechtswidrig
ein land überfallen finanzieren damit
mit den finanzierenden so also ethik
moral verständnis aus westlicher sicht
stehen gegenüber not ja und ich kann
nicht sagen wie das aufzulösen ist und
wäre ich kann nur annehmen wäre ich ein
minister im kabinett warnt ortung dann
glaube ich wäre ich in letzter sekunde
gezwungen das hörte hofreiter jetzt ich
gerne meinen amtseid erinnern dass ich
alles dafür tun muss das hier kein
schaden entsteht also butter bei die
fische sie würden verhandelt sie würden
fliegen haben ja aber nicht mit einem
putin weil das wird ja über terminologie
schon immer kaputt gemacht ja also da
wird es notwendig sein genauso wie es
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg war das dann
erst mal über otto wolff von amerongen
ging es und so weiter boden
geschäfte entwickeln hella fontänen also
nicht der kanzler nicht der
außenminister nicht der
wirtschaftsminister soll dann direkt
verhandeln und auch nicht direkt mit
herrn putin sagt thomas middelhoff
spitzenmanager 1 wie wär's mit herrn
schröder werde er dann aus ihrer sicht
der richtige dort diesen weg
einzuschlagen
na ja das ist schon so dass putin nicht
die verhandlungen für die über
gaslieferungen allerdings muss man sich
klarheit darüber verschaffen er wird die
letzte entscheidung treffen und bei der
letzten entscheidung wird das politische
gespräche geben müssen aber ich bin der
meinung wer einen besseren weg weiß wie
man die gaspreise runter kriegt die
strompreise unterricht usw der soll ist
denn sagen und das ist ja bekannt dass
ich nicht in politischen farben mit
herrn schröder
übereinstimme und insbesondere sozial
und wirtschaftspolitischen fragen das
saarland geworden dass man eben ihm
vorwirft aber das will ich vorwirft dass
eben gute verbindungen nach russland hat
dies halte ich nicht für sehr gescheit
ich bin der auffassung wir brauchen
immer wieder leute die auch
gesprächskanäle haben das hat mir im
übrigen immer zu allen leuten auch
solche die überhaupt nicht gemocht haben
die also moralisch verurteilen sind ich
will also noch einen draufsetzen wir
dürfen ja auch nicht mit beiden
verhandele ist verantwortlich für die
drohnen morgen tausende werden
rechtswidrig ermordet also warum reden
wir mit dem wenn er also tausende
verantwortlich dass 1000 rechtswidrig
ermordet werden dabei redet dann keiner
wir haben eine doppelte moral die uns
also praktisch eine sackgasse geführt
hat ja das machen sie seit langer zeit
setzten immer wieder russland mit den
usa gleich nennen die usa und auch den
präsidenten ein kriegsverbrecher bleiben
wir bitte bei der frage nach gerd
schröder herr lafontaine also das heißt
er war ja mehrfach in moskau war jetzt
mehrfach wieder bei putin er könnte der
lösende anker seien aus ihrer sicht sie
würden ihren städten jetzt schicken als
unterhändler als verhandler nein die die
vereinten die initiative muss noch von
der bundesregierung ausgehen ich habe
nur darauf hingewiesen dass es wichtig
ist wenn man leute hat die ebenen
kontakte zu anderen personen haben die
also allgemein gerechnet werden es gab
immer die geheimdiplomatie wenn es sehr
schwierig wurde und da sollte man auf
die gesprächskanäle zurückgreifen die
man hat und insofern ist das für mich
eine pure selbstverständlichkeit es kann
nicht sein dass man dem sagen moralisch
einwandfreien hat erdogan es überlässt
etwa sicherzustellen dass getreide mal
wieder geliefert wird in länder die
dringend getreide brauche weil
hungersnot herrscht es sollte jetzt
endlich mal die deutsche politik wieder
zur vernunft zurückkehren und wissen man
kann keine verlässliche außenpolitik
machen man muss politik für die menschen
in deutschland machen und dann muss man
eben einfach einen weg finden dass
energiepreise wieder bezahlbar werden so
einfach hat sie massiv an sollte den hut
nehmen und sollte lieber ein anderes
hobby pflegen als regieren dann sollten
sie den hut nehmen dann sollten sollte
er harbeck den hut nehmen frau berbalk
sagte lafontaine das einzige vernünftige
was er gesagt hat war dass am ende putin
das entscheidet alles andere was ich da
heizkörper war wenn man es ganz
freundlich ausdrücken archiv und dann
wird über irgendwelche geschichten
erzählt wie als wir das wir ein erdgas
embargo hätten ich werde aber für
nämlich dann würden wir die handelnden
werden alles haben ja gar nicht und ich
weiß nicht ob es
allen anderen entgangen ist aber scholz
hat erst vor kurzem mit putin geredet
telefoniert 90 minuten wir mitbekommen
ganz genau und deshalb hat auch nichts
gelöst machen ja nur lafontaine sagt wir
müssen weil über gas verhandelt das hat
scholz natürlich in dem telefonat war
sozusagen alles übertönt nach allem was
bekannt geworden ist nicht getan aber
bringt man zweiter mann ins spiel wir
haben gerade über gerd schröder
gesprochen oskar lafontaine wollte nicht
ganz offen sagen na das wäre jetzt der
richtige mann ina moskau zu schicken hat
ihn aber zwischen den zeilen da doch ein
bisschen gelobt wenn ich richtig
zugehört habe was wäre mit joschka
fischer das ist halt als eine absurde
vorstellung dass die dinge nicht
miteinander verknüpft werden nämlich
vorher hieß es sozusagen in 70 jahren
hat man noch keine
zweistellige inflation erlebt naja aber
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg haben wir als
auch nicht annähernd so einen krieg
erlebt er es gab den zusammenbruch
jugoslawiens
völkermorde und schrecklichen
bürgerkriege hat es ist überhaupt nicht
zu vergleichen ich glaube man muss halt
auch irgendwann mal lernen zu
akzeptieren dass wir einen schrecklichen
krieg mitten in europa und dass russland
auch schon länger einen hybriden krieg
gegen unsere serie jeden tag die bilder
das haben wir verstanden jetzt aber dann
fragen zu tun die frage ist als wenn es
keine relevanz und deswegen habe ich den
eigentlichen fischer doch und keine vor
deswegen haben kursrelevant setzen
müssten hier damit immer gehen hier
die lichter noch mal gehörig eindruck
bei vielen auch dort auf der straße ist
nach dem was unsere reporter dort
berichten wir haben dann
fachkräftemangel die in konkurrenz zur
lesung ist gerade sehr hoch das haben
die aktuellen umfrage vor einem jahr
haben fachkräfte die wir sozusagen
hätten die haben wir ins abstellt fach
gestellt und haben sie auch nicht gut
behandelt in den letzten monaten deshalb
ist das thema ihr reden über politik
über politiker fach spitzen spitzen
projekte als abseits gestellt wollen ins
abseits gestellt worden von der eigenen
partei ist zum teil auf schäbige weise
gerhard schröder geworden dass überhaupt
keine frage hat sich auch das selber ins
abseits gestellt türlich hat er sich
auch selber eingeschossen aber man hat
das ist eine ganze menge dazu getan wäre
ja dumm gewicht hauses wider die durch
ihre meinung nach durch die krise führen
könnten ja durch die krise führen muss
die amtierende regierung das ist
zunächst mal die regierungsverantwortung
wenn sie sich eines
hilfsmittels und hilfspersonal bedienen
könnte und würde dann würden in der tat
dafür gerhard schröder da sein und würde
auch joschka fischer das aber haben wir
gerade nur nicht die gesichter oder
werden die gerade in dieser krise also
wird ein harbeck wird ein scholz wird
eine frau werbung gerade zu diesen
charismatischen figuren als die wir
später genscher wahrgenommen haben und
brand wahrgenommen haben und helmut
schmidt wahrgenommen ja ich weiß nicht
welche zeitachse wir uns davor stellen
in der dann diese charismatischen
figuren entstehen sollen das im
augenblick übersteigt ist meine fantasie
was das charisma der beiden personen
angeht aber ich möchte einen punkt noch
hinzufügen der mir wichtig erscheint
herr ruf weiter weil sie alles immer so
ganz schnell ab tun dass er beinahe
schon lustigen wie sieht s schneller als
gäbe es keinen grund zur kritik herr h
weg sagt selber die komplexität des
themas übersteigt momentan seine
kapazitäten und seine fähigkeiten das
ehrt ihn dass er das sagt aber dann muss
man doch etwas dagegen tun sie können
doch auch nicht von der hand weisen dass
wir eine koalition haben die masslos
zerstritten ist und in dieser frage wo
es wirklich um gas geben beim gas geht
ständig auf der bremse steht fdp gegen
grüne und letzter punkt hofreiter ihre
partei hat dem guten herrn haben der uns
ja partiell schon leid tun kann immer
wieder
knüppel zwischen die beine geworfen
beim thema atomkraftwerke das hat die
fraktion gemacht das hat die basis
gemacht ihr seid immer noch dogmatisch
sie sind beim thema waffen sind sie
plötzlich über ihren schatten gesprungen
wunderbar chapeau aber das andere hatte
haben sie doch an habe geben gründe im
regen stehen lassen also ich muss sagen
das ist einfach wirklich
angesichts der problematik vor der wir
stehen an den haaren gezogen und an
angesichts dessen was ich gesagt habe
dass wir ganze reihe von problemen nicht
löst und dann erzählen sie hier so
geschichte man es kennt eigentlich sagen
nein eben genau nicht mehr geht einfach
drüber hinweg ich habe
gesagt ich gehe dann einfach sagt zu
drüber hinweg das tue ich eben genau
nicht ich habe gesagt dass er ganze
reihe von dingen noch nicht gelöst sind
und ich kann es auch er tritt diesmal
sang zum beispiel habe ich stand ja ja
sie haben gerade vorher gesagt man geht
einfach so traurig und das ist das was
ich meinte man nimmt angesichts der
schwierigkeit der probleme angesichts
fleck sieht angesichts dessen dass wir
mehrere krisen parallel haben wir haben
zum beispiel das problem mit den
kohlekraftwerken im sommer gehabt haben
dass die schiffe auf dem rhein fahren
konnten wegen der klima und dann sagen
sie man geht dafür sind sie in die
verantwortung natürlich gegangen auch
janna grünen minister auf genau diese
probleme zu lösen und sie aber nicht
sagen ist alles zu schwierig nein sagt
man auch nicht aber
dann so zu tun als wenn die regierung so
zu sagen einfach gar nichts gemacht hat
gar keine plan hätte so wie ich es hier
hat nachdem wir ich kann es noch mal
wiederholen flüssiggasterminals
kohlekraft haben wir verschweigen aber
sie haben es geht mir nicht darum sie
haben ja sagen noch verstanden sondern
ich finde man muss es halt ernst nehmen
und dann nicht nach dem was erläutert
hat sagen nämlich regierung habe gar
kein ich finde es nur sehr und hat auf
der aktions ich finde das eine sehr das
ist das eine sehr ernsthafte ich
verlange dass sozusagen da so reagiert
moralisch nicht geht nun von oder da
gibt es noch eine lücke die moralische
auch spezifisch hemmen heller fund den
die moralische komponente in der politik
die moral in der regierung ist die so
weit in den vordergrund geraten dass wir
den ganzen pragmatismus im moment nicht
mehr sehen zu wenig sehen
ja das ist hier aber sie ist ja immer
noch grenzenlos verlogen also sie haben
von joschka fischer angesprochen der hat
eine zusammenarbeit mit madeleine
albright
gehabt der verstorbenen us
außenministerin diese frau hat den tod
von 500 1000 kindern im irak durch
sanktionen
gerechtfertigt warum nicht ein riesen
geschrei von herrn hofreiter dass man
mit einer solchen frau zusammen arbeiten
kann dass man damit diesen tod von den
kindern ja auch noch rechtfertigt ich
bin also einfach erschüttert über diese
ungeheure doppelte moral die da ist wenn
man also verbrechen verurteilt dann muss
man sie überall verurteilen weil putin
ja aber nicht nur bei putin ab an den
anderen kameraden die ich genannt haben
die alle verfolger welch wie die kriege
und für morde und so weiter antwort ich
sind ich habe es verstanden dass auch
sie den kriegsverbrecher putin dass sie
kein fan von diesem kriegsverbrecher
putin sind wie sie sagen ja lafontaine
trotzdem die frage wenn sie verhandeln
wollen ich bin ein fan von gorbatschow
an müsste sie ja der ja leider
verstorben ist vor einigen wochen alter
von unseren leuten weiter verlangt etwas
aus über die moral
jetzt müssten sie aber in solchen
verhandlungen herrn putin oder seinen
leuten natürlich was anbieten welches
zugeständnis würden sie machen
für das angebot gas abzunehmen von ihnen
das ist ja ein angebot für sie denn sie
wollen natürlich nicht dasitzen und ihre
verbindungen zur europa was die
rohstofflieferungen angeht eben auf
dauer nicht mehr haben auch die russen
sind angewiesen auf diese lieferungen
und deswegen gilt eben der satz dass
handel auch zum frieden unsere
verständigung beiträgt wer etwas anderes
erzählt hat die geschichte ist
jahrzehnte licht studiert im edelhoff
was könnte man trotz moral trotz
unterstützung für die ukraine gibt es
irgendetwas was man anbieten könnte in
solchen verhandlungen weil das letztes
jahr voraus dass man überhaupt in diese
verhandlungen geht dass man irgendwas
vom tisch legen kann also ich habe mich
heute schon relativ weit vorgewagt das
ausgesprochen was manche denken aber
nicht auszusprechen wagen wie in der
öffentlichen meinung dass man nach
meinem dafürhalten
ich bin manager ich denke in
geldeinheiten aber ich wollte auf die
frustration von herrn hofreiter eingehen
das problem das ich will ja oder ihr
unverständnis das problem das ich hier
sehe ist wir konzentrieren alles auf
energie und ukraine tatsache an
problemen an problemursache das ist auch
zu kurz gesprungen wir haben
grundsätzliche verschiebungen im
globalen wirtschaften ja das pendel
schwingt gerade zurück wir haben
probleme in unserer gesamten
logistischen wertschöpfungskette und der
exportweltmeister deutschland mal war ja
der navigiert jetzt zwischen blöcken usa
und china ja und wird momentan gerade
richtig zerquetscht das will keiner
sehen ja und wir haben nicht mehr die
infrastruktur die so viel besser ist als
in anderen ländern wie es vor 20 jahren
war also das ist die problem
schichtungen dafür brauchst eine genaue
analyse und das ist was ich eingangs
gesagt habe wir brauchen einen
masterplan für dieses land und schals
und damit haben sie genau meine kritik
bestätigt keiner man konzentriert sich
überhaupt nicht darf das stimmt hatte
man hat zum beispiel die probleme die
wir durch die lieferketten mit china
haben ganz massiv im blick da hat man
dann nicht über weil die lösungen wir
haben zum beispiel die probleme mit dem
seltenen erden die in einer sehr
subventioniert werden ihnen aber dass
keiner im blick hat das ist halt einfach
falsch und auch da gilt es nach dem 16
jahre das land in immer tiefere
abhängigkeit von china geführt kann man
das nicht in neun monaten umkehren das
geht halt und deshalb das ist das was
mich stört dass man sozusagen
abhängigkeit von china wissen sie wie
viele arbeitsplätze in einer automobilen
es selbstverständlich in china
produzieren ja eher hoch weiter wenn
sich dann bis ihn nur noch mehr ändert
haben sie massenarbeitslosigkeit wenn
wir all das wenn herr gott wo stehen wir
in einigen monaten ein ja in einigen
jahren hier in deutsch ja gut das hängt
massiv natürlich von der zukunft unsere
energie ausstattung ab das ist der
entscheidende punkt über den wir heute
abend diskutiert haben ich sehe aber ein
weiteres aber wo sehen sie persönlich
wir haben ja am ende richtung anhand der
wir die politik messen können anhand der
wie ein bisschen in die zukunft blicken
können also wo landen wir gerade sie
meinen jetzt in der regierung oder meine
oder andere deutschland gerade als land
ist deutschland landen das ist im
augenblick ganz ganz schwer
einzuschätzen
das müssen wir natürlich abhängig machen
von der energie situation und im
augenblick sieht es
dramatisch aus sage ich mal mit blick
auch auf die unternehmer im lande
absolut dramatisch da haben wir nur
einen ganz begrenzten einblick und da
haben wir auch ein riesen problem weil
wir zwei regierungschefs hatten die
zusammen über 30 jahren reagiert hat
neben frau merkel und herrn kohl beide
haben kein interesse an der wirtschaft
gehabt das muss man so sehen
die haben daher historiker die andere
war physiker wenn sie hatten kein
interesse an der wirtschaft und ich sage
jetzt noch mal was auch die medien haben
natürlich insgesamt zu wenig interesse
an wirtschaftlichen zusammenhängen und
das tut natürlich einem land und ihre
frage wohin führt es denn natürlich
alles andere und genau das vertiefen sie
und damit rechnen sie ab auch in ihrem
neuen buch so nicht heißt dass
tatsächlich eine abrechnung mit der
bundesregierung bei dem ich mich nur
gefragt habe warum das wenn sie so lange
journalismus waren so lange
chefredakteur waren erst jetzt kommt
ganz kurze antwort warum weil ich jetzt
die muße hat seit mit genügend leute
jetzt können sie die menschen der
politik streng auf die finger schauen
oskar lafontaine wo landet das land war
die frage wirtschaftlich wir sehen
anders wohnrechts wo beispielsweise in
italien aktuell ist das auch unsere
zukunft hier in den nächsten monaten
jahren
denn wenn das so weitergeht ist das eine
große gefahr
das lehrt uns die geschichte
wenn massenverarmung eintritt
massenarbeitslosigkeit wenn das
vertrauen in die regierung sinkt dann
wird die rechte stark insofern geht es
also erstens einmal um die armen leute
den wir helfen müssen zweitens um den
wirtschaftsstandort den wir retten
müssen eine industriestaat und
deutschland nicht einer der wichtigsten
industriestaaten der welt braucht
preiswerte energie und preiswerte
rohstoffe aber drittens geht es darum
die politische stabilität die jetzige
politik der ampel führt zum erstarken
der rechten das werden wir in den
nächsten monaten sehen das wird alles
andere wird ihr bestreben sei nicht dass
herr hofreiter werden sie dieses problem
in den nächsten wochen und monaten lösen
werden und wenn ich es schaffe probleme
wird man lösen denn man darf nicht
vergessen wir haben sehr viel billiger
energie in unserem land und die müssen
jetzt schnell ausbauen das photovoltaik
produziert ihnen den strom für zwei cent
windkraft für vier bis fünf cent und das
muss man jetzt schnell heben nämlich
beim strom produzieren gerade sehr viele
sehr viel günstiger energie wir müssen
dazu die marktmechanismen ändern nicht
die leute können das nicht mehr zahlen
und es kann nicht sein dass ein
unternehmen dessen strom für 3 cent
produziert in für 70 cent verkaufen
lösen und karl
anton hofreiter hier heute noch einmal
bei bild bei den richtigen fragen danke
für lebhafte diskussionen an sigmund
gottlieb an anton hofreiter an thomas
middelhoff und was ich zu hause an oskar
lafontaine danke ihnen wir sind zurück
am nächsten montag 22 15
[Musik]